I live in California my state is garbage
my state is just terrible I have the
right to say that it's a hellhole I can
say that because I've been here my
entire life I was born in California I
was raised in California I was married
in Calvin was married in Israel and
California and and I've lived my entire
life in California really like except
for three years where I was in Cambridge
Massachusetts hanging out with the the
Elizabeth Warren crew except for that
I've been in California my entire life
and it is getting progressively worse
and I use the word progressively
advisedly because the more progressive
it grows the Dumber it grows so we
decided we were going to elect an idiot
Kendall as the as the governor of the
state of California
this Kendall said he was gonna solve
homelessness in San Francisco and
completely failed to do so instead
helping turn San Francisco into a poop
filled needle mess and then we were like
oh let's make him governor and he has
presidential aspirations does Gavin
Newsom so Gavin Newsom gave his State of
the State address the other day and in
his State of the State address he
addressed the fact that California has
become the world's leading center of
homelessness or at least the America's
leading center of homelessness we have
by the way something like 65,000
homeless people counted in Los Angeles
County alone like Dodger Stadium worth
of homeless people in LA County you
cannot walk down the street any Street
in Los Angeles without people engaging
in public urination or defecation or
needle use they you I believe it was
Herbert Hoover who promised a chicken in
every pot in LA they promised a homeless
person on every bench there great
solution was that they were gonna put
bars on the benches like in the middle
of the bench that homeless people can't
actually lie across the benches and it
turns out that human beings being
adaptable homeless people mention
throwing blankets over those bars and
they just sleeping right over them like
they don't really care so it's because
it's a wonderful city and we pay
exorbitant taxes and California as a
state we pay unbelievably high taxes the
highest tax rates in the nation 13.3 top
income tax bracket and it kicks in and
like I think a hundred thousand dollars
a year or something it's it's very very
low kickin anyway Gavin Newsom gave his
State of the State address in which he
said it was a disgrace we have so much
homelessness conveniently forgetting
that um he is the governor and was also
the mayor of San Francisco and is
horrible at both jobs let's call it what
it is it's a disgrace that the richest
state in the richest nation
succeeding across so many sectors is
falling so far behind a properly housed
heal and humanely treat so many of its
own people everyday the California Dream
is is dimmed by the wrenching reality of
families children and seniors living
unfed on a concrete bed
okay well I'm you know who's responsible
for that that would be like a you and
the Democrats who have run Sacramento
virtually my entire adult life fund and
you may have something to do with that
do you not
so what proposals did Gavin Newsom bring
to the table on homelessness well as a
Ken doll there's not a lot between the
ears so Gavin Newsom brought a few
proposals here's one of his proposals he
says what if we just like said that
people have a legal right to shelter
what if we just said that now last I
checked when you say somebody has a
legal right to a thing this carries with
it a couple of implications one either
nothing happens because you declared it
right and it doesn't materialize for
example there's a right to housing in
the South African Constitution
homelessness in South Africa a very
large thing you can declare anything
right that doesn't mean it materializes
if I declare the other right to pancakes
this morning I'm not gonna make it a
pancakes nobody's gonna make it a
pancakes at the bank a saint can will
appear if I declare that you have a
right to housing that does not make the
housing appear or is Gavin Newsom saying
that if you have a legal right to
housing you can now sue the state to
provide you the housing which means that
the state will be forced to raise taxes
to build the housing or does it mean
that the state can force developers to
rent out their properties at rates that
are non beneficial lowering development
causing increased taxes causing
increased spending on garbage public
housing which will promptly be wrecked
by homeless people because a lot of
those homeless people in order to clean
out would actually need to abide by
certain restrictions but you can have
those restrictions because you have a
legal right to housing in other words
this is idiocy but here is Gavin Newsom
doing the idiotic thing because welcome
to California in order don't get the job
done we've got to match this new money
with a new legal obligation to address
the crisis head-on requiring that any
new funding isn't replacing existing
spending but creating new solutions some
have recommended a legal right to
shelter I know it's a provocative idea
which is forced this state to explore
the limits of what
local governments can be compelled to do
but right now our imperative I believe
must be about bringing governments
together as working partners not
sparring partners in a court of law so
um if you give everybody illegal rights
of shelter that you're making everybody
sparring-partners in a court of law
that's that's what it does and then
you've now casted into the courts which
is the entire purpose of course men he
says what if doctors could write
prescriptions for housing what is the
good write prescriptions for housing
what the hell is he talking about now
not to put too fine a point on it but as
you know I have a close relationship
with a doctor a close sexual
relationship with a doctor my wife I
know hot but my wife should not be able
to write prescriptions for housing
that's idiocy she's she doesn't know
anything about housing she doctor she
can write a prescription for drugs she
can write prescription for
pharmaceuticals
she can read prescription for a
follow-up appointment she can't write a
prescription for a two-bedroom condo in
Studio City what the hell are you
talking about gavin newsom
McGavin Newsome doesn't understand how
doctors work so here he is but doctors
should write prescriptions for housing
health care and housing can no longer be
divorced after all what's more
fundamental to a person's well-being
than a roof over their head doctors
doctors should be able to write
prescriptions for housing the same way
they do for insulin and antibiotics what
in the what okay but the good news is
the Gavin Newsom says that what has
really helped Californians is that we
are now providing tax free tampons and
diapers this is what's helping
Californians save money so we've really
we've really fixed all the problems guys
now obviously the answer to a lot of the
homelessness problems in the state of
California is to lower taxes increased
investment increased investment in
development release people from rent
control and criminalize people who are
trespassing or engaging in public drug
use public defecation make sure that
people either are forced into mandatory
drug rehab or that they are treated in
ways that they need to be treated
they're mentally ill they get the drugs
that they need right but he's not gonna
do any of that stuff instead he's just
gonna talk about how yeah sure we got
hundreds of thousands of homeless people
across the state of California what if
we declared a legal right or putting on
doctors and also here's some free
tampons the working parent with more
money in our pocket thanks to expanded
paid family leave $1,000 family tax
credit and in lower costs due to tax
free diapers and tampons yep well and
whoo California man sure open needles on
the streets poop on the corner well
combined stuff with your kids and
residential areas but those diapers are
tax free guys don't you feel better now
don't you feel better
this state is trash it's a good news why
don't why don't we like take that and
just expand it across the whole nation
Democrats do such a great job they do
such a great job
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content